-Hi, y'all. I'm Liza Koshy.
And today,
I'm going to be trying
Thanksgiving Dinner Candy Corn.
Let's go.
♪♪
The flavors that
we have today are...
Ugh! I'm good.
Alright, here we go.
[ Chuckles ]
Alright, we'll start off with
a little Apple Pie.
I like dessert first.
Here we go.
Apple Pie.
It's disgusting.
I'm just kidding.
It's actually pretty good.
Oh, that's delightful!
It's just compacted sugar.
Yeah, you can't go wrong.
That's good.
We're starting off with
a really nice palate.
My taste buds are enjoying this.
I would say this is like an...
8.
[ Ding ]
I think it's downhill from here,
because the next one is
Roasted Turkey.
And I just recently became
a freegan,
which is free to be vegan when
you want to be, but isn't often.
But I haven't had turkey in
a very long time, so here we go.
Roasted Turkey.
Oh, that's -- Oh, that's weird.
That tastes
a little bit like vomit.
[ Laughs ]
You know that jelly-bean game?
That...
Why is it spicy?
That has a very savory flavor.
I can taste the glaze.
That was dark meat.
No. It was white meat.
Interesting. I give that a...
I give that a 4.
[ Buzzer ]
4. 4.
Green Beans is next, though.
Ooh!
Happy Thanksgiving, everybody.
Um...
That's not green beans.
That's grass.
That tastes like
freshly cut grass.
It tastes like a lawnmower.
I'm gonna give that a...
I'm gonna give that a 1.
[ Buzzer ]
That's generous, though.
That's generous.
Next one is Stuffing.
What is Stuffing?
It's different in
every household.
What's Stuffing?
Stuffing's in my mouth now.
I made it into the spit bucket.
That was a negative-4.
[ Buzzer ]
Next, cranberry sauce.
Can you see the pain in my eyes?
Yes, you can.
Refreshing.
Palate cleanser.
Tastes like a vodka-cran,
which is what I'm gonna go for
after this experience.
That's a 7.
[ Ding ]
That's good. That's good.
Am I high or is it the sugar?
[ Laughs ]
Alright, last.
Could be the least.
No, actually,
it's definitely not least.
It's coffee.
A little espresso
palate cleanser.
[ Rattling ]
Save some of those for later,
'cause that was my favorite.
That was a 10.
[ Ding ]
We ended on a high note.
Don't go get yours now.
They were disgusting.
4 out of 10.
Bye-bye.